we're delighted to wish you all a very
happy st patrick's day
how come you got that easy man kate
middleton and prince william
couldn't be cuter in their new st
patrick's day video message
the duke and duchess of cambridge make a
cameo in the video compilation of world
leaders including u.s president joe
biden and canadian prime minister justin
trudeau
which was released by the irish foreign
ministry on wednesday
in the clip william kicks things off by
sharing a message
in the traditional irish language
we're delighted to wish you all a very
happy st patrick's day
how come you got that easy man and the
two reflect on their last trip to
ireland which took place in early march
2020
just days before the start of the global
pandemic
we were so thrilled to be able to visit
ireland just over a year ago
a few short weeks before all of our
lives were turned upside down by the
pandemic
the warm welcome that we received
everywhere was a testament to the
friendship between our two countries
and the strength of the relationship
between the uk and ireland
while the couple was all smiles in the
clip behind the scenes
there's turmoil within the royal family
as they navigate the response to the
tell
all oprah winfrey interview with
william's younger brother prince harry
and his wife meghan markle the talk at
the palace is that they are
absolutely horrified by what has been
said they feel that
harry has literally thrown the family
under a bus
cbs this morning anchor gail king who is
also a close friend to oprah winfrey
and attended meghan markle's baby shower
when she was pregnant with archie
opened up on the morning news program
about the conversation
she says she had with the couple
following their interview with oprah
that aired earlier this month the word i
was given was that the
those conversations were not productive
but they are glad that there they have
at least started a conversation
william is is devastated by this
interview don't forget the duchess of
cambridge has been dragged into this
whole saga
and william will will hate that um and
of course relationship between father
and son is now
at an all-time low during the 90-minute
special with oprah
harry talked about his older brother
prince william and his dad prince
charles
and said at one point charles stopped
talking to him amid his decision to step
down as a senior member of the royal
family
no one is in the royal family has talked
to megan yet
at this particular time and i think it's
frustrating for them to see that it's a
racial conversation about the royal
family when
all they wanted all along was for the
royals to intervene and tell the press
to stop
with the unfair uh inaccurate false
stories that definitely have a racial
slant and until you can acknowledge that
i think it's going to be hard to move
forward but they both want to move
forward with this
and they both want you know they want
healing in this family at the end of the
day that is harry's family
last week prince william broke his
silence following megan and harry's
interview
in which megan claimed that prior to
giving birth to archie
one of the royal family members
expressed concern about the potential
color of his skin
sir have you broke have you spoken to
your brother since the interview
i haven't spoken yet but i will do and
can you just let me know is that the
royal family a racist family sir
we're very much not a racist while they
were graced for
for something explosive they totally
underestimated
just how far harry and megan would go
and i think they took everyone by
surprise